وبينما يركز خصومه الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب على قضيته الجنائيه لادانته على
مسرح محكمه نيويورك امام العالم اجمع
ترامب يزداد توجهه ويعزز هويته الوطنيه
ويروج لحملته تحضيرا للسباق الرئاسي
القادم ويختزل قضيه اتهامه بوضعها على
هامش الطريق هكذا قرات صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز سلوكا ترامب الذي تعامل بذكاء مع
قضيته الجنائيه واعتبرها مشهدا عابرا
وليست قضيه خطيره لدرجه انه شوه مصداقيتها
على الاقل في نظر مؤيديه وبدلا من
الاختباء من اهانه تسليم نفسه الى السلطات
ارسل ترامب جدلا زمنيا كما لو كان في جوله
انتخابيه ليخبر الجميع بكل خطواته قبل
وصوله الى محكمه نيويورك وارسل ترامب
بريدا الكترونيا لجمع التبرعات بعناوين
يخشاها السياسيون الاخرون مثل الرئيس
المتهم نعم لقد تم اتهامي ولكن وهذه
العناوين رد عليها مؤيدوه باعطائه المال
ووصل المبلغ الى اربعه ملايين دولار خلال
24 ساعه فقط بعد صدور قرار اتهامه وعدا عن
ذلك مشاهدينا ترامب الذي يقترب من عقده
التاسع يبقى المرشح المفضل لدى حزبه
الجمهوري بعدما كشفت اخر استطلاعات الراي
تقدمه في الانتخابات التمهيديه للحزب
الجمهوري لعام 2004
مجله نيوزويك الامريكيه بدورها اعتبرت ان
مدعي عام من هاتنبراج اعاد انتخاب ترامب
مره اخرى لان ادعاءاته مشكوك بها واستندت
نيوزويك ايضا الى تقارير نشرتها صحيفه
واشنطن بوست المناهضه بشده تقول فيها ان
اتهامات المدعي العام براج غير مقنعه وان
المحاكمه يجب الا تستمر لان براج نفسه غير
مقتنع بتجريم ترامب لانه تخلى عن القضيه
قبل عام ولم يعد احياءها او لم يعد
احيائها الا بعد ان تعرض للخذلان من قبل
اثنين من اتباعه بعد استقالتهما بسبب هذا
القرار